AFTER SESSION CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE GALLAGHER
CHILD CARE TO IN
COLLEGE HI HOLDEN
CALL KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE RIGHT
WE DO HAVE A FORM WE HAVE
ONE BILL FORCE AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONE DISCUSS IT YEAH
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND -- I AM ACCEPTING
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE USED TO WITH OUR OTHER
COMMITTEE AFTER THINKING VERY
WORK WITH THAT THE STORY HIRE
A COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF
LOCAL LAND USE POLICIES ON
THE FINE AND TEN AND ON GOING
BASIS WE HAD A LONG WEEK I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I BOTH
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
SINGER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE ALL RIGHT SIGNAL
ASK FOR AN ADULT THANK YOU FOR
MOTION IS TO PASS A MESSAGE
TO APPROPRIATIONS CALDERON
I'VE GALLAGHER CHILD
-- I SHALL I CHOOSE AND SALAS
I CAN SOLVE AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN
AYE KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
AYE KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE FIVE PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE THE
OTHER MEMBERS IN OTHER
COMMITTEE SO I'M GONNA HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR AWHILE THE
CASE THEY WANT TO RUN BACK
DOWN IF YOU VOTED THE BILL
IS OUT HAVE A NICE WEEKEND
NO WAY OUT
WELL OKAY